but the judges in the end the DA even
said that they didn't know that you have
one of these devices why is that I have
nothing more to say D stingrays are
travelling cell towers controlled by
law-enforcement agencies they are so
powerful they force all cellular devices
in up to a mile radius to connect to
them
Sacramento sheriff deputies have been
planed NSA by driving around with
suitcase sized stingrays yeah I'm gonna
sting grab my freaking ex Janine the
department has been secretly using the
spy technology for years
Janine would be so jealous if I join the
NSA and deputies reportedly do their
shady business without warrants I've
learned what the warrant or if you're
using stingrays I think there are some
questions about that then this interview
can be over but hey what's the big deal
after all the feds tell local agencies
to play fast and loose with their new
toys a series of emails obtained by the
ACLU reveal that the US Marshal Service
has been telling police in Florida to
keep the Stingray spying hush-hush
freaking a don't want to hear about the
privacy crap one email reads at the
request of the u.s. marshals the
investigative means utilized to locate
the suspect have not been revealed in
reports or depositions we simply refer
to the assistance as received
information from a confidential source
hey you met my CI right first named
sting wouldn't want some nosy judge or
defense attorney to find out take away
my sting where and what I got to do like
some real police work
no thank you you still with me you
filming it but come on don't cops have
better things to do
stingrays are all the rage these days
USA Today reports that dozens of state
local
Apartments are playing Anna same can't
believe she left me for that firefighter
them guys don't work ever but instead of
hiding a line about using stingrays why
not try something wacky like telling the
truth while asking a judge for a warrant
or bad from the eighties yeah they're
pretty good appeals to the Fourth
Amendment may not swim cops so how about
this obtaining evidence illegally could
mean that bad guys go free off at the
Ted out follow the show on Twitter
submit your nominees for next month and
check out Paul Burton this month's
featured follower this is a big shot
with Twitter and me are you twittering
me it was jaywalking a lot of watch